hello this is presh talwalkar
this is the fourth video in the series
on how to solve the rubik's cube where i
explain how to solve the middle layer
we've solved the first layer
which means we have all of the edge
pieces matching the center
and all of the corner pieces in the
correct position with the correct
orientation
since the white layer is completely
solved what we're going to do is turn
the cube upside down
this will make it easier for us to see
the pieces that we want to identify to
solve the middle layer
the middle layer consists of four pieces
with two colors each
so let's see if any of these edge pieces
are on the top
so here we identify one of the pieces
which is red and green and we'll rotate
the red side so it matches the red side
here we have an orange and blue face
we'll deal with that in a moment
so now we have red matching the red side
and we want to move this to the right
so we're looking at the red side we're
matching the red side and we need to
move this edge piece to the right
so here's how we can do that without
messing anything else up
we go u
r
u prime
r prime
u prime
f prime
u
and finally f
and lo and behold we've moved the edge
piece to the middle
layer
in the correct orientation
and we haven't messed anything else up
so we'll continue solving the middle
layer we'll look for any of the edge
pieces that are on the top and here we
identify red and blue
so we're going to rotate this until the
red matches
the red center
and now
we need to move this piece to the left
so this is pretty much the same move as
when we moved it to the right but it'll
be
relative to the left
so we go u prime
l prime
u
l
u
f
u prime
and f prime
and now we put this red and blue piece
in the correct position
and every other piece that we've solved
so far in the bottom layer and the
middle layer has stayed in position
so now we're going to keep looking for
edge pieces
so here we have an orange and green
piece
and we're going to want to move we match
the orange to the center and we want to
move this to the left
so we do our same sequence of moves for
that we go
u prime
l prime
u
l
u
f
u prime
and f prime
we have one final piece
this is orange and blue and we need to
move it to the right so we're going to
use the move which moves it to the right
that's u
r
u prime
r prime
u prime
f prime
u
and f
and now we've solved the entire middle
layer
but before i go on to the next video i'm
just going
to show you one last thing
in this case we had all of the edge
pieces that were on the top and we
simply move them to where they need it
to be
but it might happen while you're solving
a cube
that you end up in an unlucky situation
so here's an example
where while we're looking around
you know we have this red and green
piece that's stuck
and sometimes you may you may need to
get that piece unstuck
so
if it's not on the top it's just stuck
in the middle layer
you need to get that to the top layer
so in order to do that what you can do
is you can use you can
you know move one of the other pieces
there so here we have an edge piece
that's on the top and we want to move it
to the right
so we use our move
which gets that piece
to the right side
and what that'll do is that'll un you
know that'll take out the edge piece
that was in the wrong spot and bump it
up to the top layer
so once we do that that red and green
piece we've moved it to the top
and now we can go ahead and solve the
rest of the cube
using the moves of left and right to get
to the middle layer
i'll go ahead and do that and now we
have to move this to the left so
i'll take care of
that and
using those two moves of left and right
we can always solve the middle layer
i hope you like this video please click
through to find out how to solve the
third and final layer
please subscribe to my channel
you can support me on patreon
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
on twitter at presh talwalkar and you
can get my books listed on my website